so the way i kind of see it is the right
is a meritocracy
and the left is a command economy uh it
makes perfect sense
they that's the policy they want it's
the government they want
and the right tends to be if the idea is
good
it goes viral and so the right has this
advantage on the internet
in that virality among right-wing memes
only happens if everyone agrees and it's
it's
it's not like there's no vote there's no
argument it's quite literally you make
the meme
and do enough people think it's good you
know what that is really interesting
because
you're basically throwing your meme out
there to be voted on
right you're like what do you think
about this do you think this is true
does everybody agree with this does
everyone want to argue with this because
i like doing that i'll post memes
sometimes i'm like i want to see what
people say about this
but if it's funny you'll share it right
absolutely and so i shared this one meme
where it's the guy from the dnc dancing
and then the comment on youtube says
we're going to lose aren't we it's
perfect
it's it's the perfect and cap like this
feeling everybody's kind of having
you know these demo like they're you're
watching the democrats wake up to how
cringy it is
i decided to share that out of all the
memes right so this one is getting a ton
of traction because it resonates with
people
it shares an idea on the left they don't
do this and that's why they struggle to
meme
because someone has to tell them what is
acceptable otherwise they'll get
cancelled
you're right so it's all it's all kind
of a mix a mish
it's not just one thing though it's like
you know yin yang it's these two
two different schools the right doesn't
care about being offensive
because if they are the idea just
disappears and no one shares it
if it truly does like bother the greater
hive it doesn't go anywhere
yeah because let's say you have a
hundred people and they're
you know independent internet-based
right-wing moderate you know anti-sw
whatever this weird group of people is
someone could post something and it
could be just
offensive to any human and no one in
their group
cares to share it or it could be a
really funny joke from dave chappelle or
family guy or something and they all
start sharing and laughing
then as soon as it reaches people on the
left they look at it and look around
what should i say or do
and they wait for their priests or
authorities to confirm
hey look at this thing it's funny that's
why you always see the same exact memes
shared by the left
like that xkcd comic on free speech oh
my gosh
for those who don't know it's just one
where this it's a comic that conflates
free speech of the first amendment
it's not it's just so wrong or the one
by that guy
where it's a dude popping out of a well
saying
there's like a peasant saying we should
improve society and he goes yeah you
live in society
and that's the the only ideas they share
are the approved ideas that everyone
else is sharing
whereas you go on the right and it's
like like i often mention i think one of
the best examples is gay married dave
rubin hanging out with
orthodox jew ben shapiro clearly they
don't agree
but they agree enough that we're people
we get along we have to
you know learn to live together and so
ultimately going back to this poll
i i i think it's actually really
fascinating how much i've been able to
milk this one tweet in this long
conversation
really good conversation but i think i
think i
i i i think i kind of just figured
something out you know yeah
well yeah it's just exactly what i said
a leftist post
posted a poll that should have for every
for every reason
shown q anon to be more uh dangerous
than antifa
yeah but it was antifa so that says one
or two things
maybe her followers really did think
antifa was more dangerous i doubt
it or they don't care enough to actually
share it unless prompted by an authority
figure
and she doesn't have the authority she's
not
a big brand she's not a democratic
politician she's not a high profile
social justice warrior or anything like
that she's a low profile one
but on the right if it's funny they'll
share it and everyone agreed
vote antifa and the only reason it went
viral was because
right wing people did think that it was
funny that is interesting it makes me
wonder a little bit how many times
left-wing
people look at memes from left or right
and think you know what
that's really funny i'm not gonna share
it but it's really funny and i
like it i don't think they do no i don't
really yeah i don't
i think i think one thing that separates
what means yeah but we think they're
funny
so so look why is it that someone like
me who could be a liberal
my whole life i mean i was far left when
i was younger i i've like i wrote a
bunch of anti-government you know
anti-war songs and stuff when i was a
teenager
listen to all this punk rock stuff how
did i then become liberal
and now here i am you know i hang out
with people across the spectrum
i even i have friends who are far left
it's very difficult it's very difficult
but no now i'm looking at the election
and i'm like i think for these reasons
i gotta vote for trump a lot of the
reasons that jack murphy pointed out how
does that happen
it's very simple i have a sense of humor
right
they don't i wonder what it is that
makes a sense of humor and i thought a
lot about this because i think it
requires a lot more humility than they
can have
and i think their religion makes them so
stiff
that they can't bend in any way
otherwise they just absolutely shatter
it wasn't this the moral authoritarian
christian
right this used to be the right wing in
the 90s and i remember
thinking that it was boring because it
was and it was kind of repressive and
sad and i didn't really like it
and then something happened and all of a
sudden along comes you know ben shapiro
and all these videos start popping up on
youtube where it's like
ben shapiro destroys you know college
leftists with facts and logic
and it was hilarious and it was a meme
and
he laughs at it and the funniest thing
to me about ben shapiro
is that he is super buttoned up and even
he can laugh at this stuff he thinks
it's funny he's like yes make fun of me
for telling you that my wife's a doctor
because
they both worked really hard for that
and they have three kids and everything
like that's some hard work
i think to them there are there are some
people in
the in the sjw space who can't take a
joke
oh yeah who get super offended oh yeah
but like i said before it's like inverse
proportions
forever you know out of 10 people two
people on the trump side can't take a
joke
but eight can on the left two people can
take a joke eight can't
so i i you know what i often explain
this people
you go to a trump rally the worst thing
that's gonna happen to you is someone's
gonna insult you like if you
if you come in there and you bring anger
and animosity i mean
you can start a fight i just don't see
it happening if you insult somebody or
make a joke and mock trump people are
probably gonna be like i don't know
whatever and they're gonna ignore you
you go to a left-wing counter protest
and you
even resemble anything so there was
there was somebody uh
at one event who was wearing a red hat
because you know you know they make the
the maga hats but they're parodies yeah
oh i remember that somebody got attacked
yeah because
oh yeah yeah it was um i'm for i'm
forgetting
the name it it wasn't uh where was this
i can't remember okay i thought i was
gonna remember
it was in berkeley somebody wore a red
hat that said make
bitcoin great again yeah i remember that
that was when that lady was attacked
that was why she got attacked because
she was wearing a red hat with white
writing
that's it dude that's all it takes it's
really funny because i see
i've seen some some of these leftists
wear hats that say make america gay
again
right and i thought to myself i saw this
they're gonna attack you for that
there when i was in san jose when this
is a really crazy story we had we had
carrie smith on
just a couple days ago she's a liberal
voting for trump one of the things that
changed her mind was she watched a video
of a guy getting whacked in the back of
the head with a bag i actually filmed
that
so weird yeah but at that event there
was a man who got punched in the mouth
like in his face he was bleeding from
his from his mouth they just thought he
was a trump supporter
and he was with the riot wow so they
they just
the others you're under fire you're
under attack but anyway more
more to the point about a sense of humor
i watch donald trump at his rallies
yeah and i am a mature adult with
critical thinking abilities
and i see him make a joke
self-deprecating and i laugh along with
everybody else
and my answer is being a funny
entertainer
does not change my mind on political
opinion
at this point however things are so
messed up i certainly would never
want by you know biden or harris or
whatever and trump has done
you know better things but i've never
had a problem that is probably why
i'm some people try to argue i have
trump derangement syndrome and it's the
stupidest thing
i think it's the stupidest thing ever
because i'm just
you know there's some things i've been
critical of but i think he's pretty much
improved greatly
in the past year or so but i think one
of the reasons why
i would personally say i don't and why i
don't care that much is
just because i have a sense of humor
right they don't i think it might
i think a sense of humor may actually be
a symptom maybe it's critical thinking
ability
or or confidence maturity i think it is
and and like i was saying i think that
it is humility and it's a little bit of
self-reflection and you have to be okay
with not being perfect
because like they say if you laugh at
yourself like donald trump does
you will never run out of material and
you'll never be bored either
and i think that watching a politician
who has a sense of humor about
themselves
is refreshing to people because you
watch people like lori lightfoot and
bill de blasio and they lose and andrew
cuomo just looks like he hates his job
they won't ever take responsibility for
anything
right and then they complain trump
doesn't and
for the most part trump doesn't i would
say for the most part but there is a
difference
he he does he he doesn't go as hard as
they do
i mean look i'm not going to pretend you
know that i'm some some
you know raging trump supporter i'm not
i don't think he's perfect i think
a lot even a lot of trump supporters
recognize that for sure
but i i've watched trump make fun of
himself for being orange
yeah and it's funny i went to the white
house
for that social media summit and i
thought it was going to be like a
roundtable sit down
talking about serious problems in
silicon valley and i was actually asked
what what i hope to bring and i said
a lot of conservatives feel that they
are
you know the only people being targeted
in this way and i want to i want to add
those anti-establishment leftists who
also
it's a lot less of them it's
predominantly conservative but i want to
make sure i can represent
the the former occupy people that a
bunch of them got banned there was like
one day where 50 accounts just got
purged for no reason oh
yeah and there's some anti-war accounts
that have been have been purged as well
and so i was like i want to make sure i
can be be fair and represent this
in a way that can allow us to actually
you know accurately talk about what's
going on
instead it was donald trump doing
stand-up i'm not kidding it's like a
mini rally
it was stand up yeah it was brilliant
stand-up
everybody was laughing the whole time he
was self-deprecating
and it really tears down a lot of the
things they say about him
when he addresses it in a humorous way
like when that one thing where he was
like the lights in here
they're making me look orange i don't
know what's going on everybody had
laughed about it yeah absolutely so did
it change your perspective of him to go
and listen to him talk about himself in
that way
i've listened i've been at trump rally
since he started running oh yeah that's
right yeah
when i worked for fusion i went to
several dozen trump rallies
and this is probably something else that
you know inoculated me from trump
derangement syndrome
maybe the most severe case maybe it
maybe i was overly critical in the past
whatever
but i met a bunch of trump supporters i
remember i was in florida it was like
fort lauderdale
and i was talking to this middle-aged
woman she said she never voted before
she was not registered with any party
she was independent
but trump was talking about things she
cared about and she felt like
it was anti-establishment it was finally
somebody who was talking back to the
machine
it's interesting because there's
similarities
in the woke left and the right in terms
of
what they want focused on perhaps it's
an issue of being right or wrong
like the the tactic is is neutral
but the the assumption so what i mean to
say is
the left will tell you you can't succeed
because
the color of your skin because of your
identity donald trump will tell you you
can't succeed because the billionaire
owners of the auto factory moved that
plant to china
because a bunch of politicians came in
and they say say no more we know
all of that because we experience them
do it so you could probably say
something like
if your factory is is it leaves your
area then you need to figure out how to
start a factory
which is yeah i'm i'm you know playing
devil's advocate like
why don't you go build your own build
your own yeah but
for these people there there was a
specific issue that
legitimately impacted the economy and
trump
he proved it he started doing you know
tariffs he started securing the borders
he started dealing with immigration all
of a sudden unemployment was dropping
factories were coming back this was all
part of his plan the economy was booming
these people voted for him because he
said here's the problem
and a bunch of them said yes we cut we
quite literally witnessed that
that thing happened and this policy
could change that
the left just says you know a
multi-millionaire black woman has less
privilege than homeless white men
which is nonsensical and subjective
moralistic and and irrelevant to policy
yeah i have always kind of noticed this
about him and for all of the
times i've face-palmed over something
that he's tweeted
i have never ever felt like he did not
care what happened to american workers
watching him actually engage he is not
the politician who goes and engages in
fights with people who are supposed to
be supporting him
that baffled me about joe biden like
watching him mix it up with those blue
collar workers in the
background yeah look i see why your wife
left you what are you talking about
he doesn't want to win i don't think he
does and watching trump
actually engage it's like he seems to
care he really does
i have this a really funny idea yeah and
i would love to do some sketches
we're going to have um i don't know if
you guys know who ryan long is you
should know who he is he's a very funny
comedian yes
he's gonna be hanging out here uh next
week at some point but
i'm just imagining joe biden is behind
this behind the scenes
talking crystal clear and he's like you
know he's having a beer and then he's
like he looks at his watch and he's like
oh i gotta go on
and then he like jams cotton in his
mouth to like purposefully cause himself
to slur
and then he goes out there and he
purposefully just gaffs everything and
fumbles
and then when he goes back behind stage
once it's all over he just looks at his
friends
and they all start laughing maniacally
like yeah it's the whole it's all it's
all a bit
they're just trying to lose he's
insulting his own supporters
my favorite is that he's told multiple
people not to vote for him
yes what that's his crowning achievement
thus far
when my favorite was the guy who was
trying to support him he was like
you know i see i can't remember exactly
what he said but he was like i see what
you're saying but
you know if you don't want to do this
like what do you say to these people and
he goes then vote for trump
and the guy goes no no i don't want to
vote for trump i'm asking questions no
you go vote for trump
okay all right i guess i will i can't
believe that he did that man
yeah i'm feeling uh cnn that cnn poll
came out
uh yeah 15 battleground states trump's
at one point behind biden
my goodness and the margin of error is
four points that is quite the gap that
he closed over the last like four days
what happened the last four days well
there's two big things yeah kamala
harris
she is unlikable yep they
though cnn says you know 54 percent or i
think it's 53
approve of the choice and it's like okay
so 47 percent didn't
yeah right so how many votes are you
going to lose last half but sure okay i
guess you know
just over half support it she she takes
the majority but she's unlikable
that shouldn't raise donald trump's
approval rating but it should close the
presidential polling gap between who
you're going to vote for
so that makes sense but for donald
trump's approval rating recently spiked
according to rasmussen to 51
and with it with a disapproval of 47
keeping in mind it's only one poll so
this could just be static
however rasmussen was correct in 2016. i
always try to preface this
i think it has to do with this massive
ad buy trump did you don't think it's
because of the dnc
that's what i'm saying not approval
rating oh yeah closing so it wouldn't
make sense that people would be like
joe biden is stupid therefore i like
trump again or like or now i like trump
what would make sense is that when you
ask someone who you're going to vote for
and they say joe biden someone else says
donald trump
you get you know joe biden a 14-point
lead then you show them the dnc
and then they come back and go can i
change my vote yeah i'm gonna revise my
options
right that closes the gap because not
because they approve of trump
but they prefer him however trump's
approval rating recently spiked
just according to rasmussen i think this
is because of the major ad buy what
would make people say i like trump
they saw an ad from trump about joe
biden and they went wow i didn't know
that
right and of course the media is going
to claim he's lying and none of it's
true
whatever yeah you know what man i
i can't believe trump recently came that
goodyear thing that happened with the
the boycott yeah trump don't buy it then
there was leaked audio it's a crazy
story
but i i see i see this friend i have on
facebook and he just posts in response
to trump's post
he's like i'm gonna go by goodyear now
and i'm like is that your life
if trump says it you do the opposite
that's all you do
well that's been working for the dnc
hasn't it
well maybe but no maybe right right i
think
when you look at the polls if you take
it all at face value and believe the
journalists then
sure but i don't i don't think so don't
buy it
no not with the riots anymore not with
the uh
all these people buying guns yeah you
have to convince me that all of these
liberals who went out bought guns and
they did they did in urban areas like
new york and la they went out bought
guns
that all of a sudden they're holding the
weapon in their hands
and then the democrat goes on tv and
says ban all guns they go okay i just
bought it but sure
i'm gonna give it back now let me get
let me get rid of the thing that i
thought would protect me and my family
when someone told me i couldn't have you
know security around my house
it was luxury before the riots before
covid
people were like yeah cops take care of
it
yeah it was a golden age it was i mean
i'm guilty of it too
i was i'm not worried we got we got a
local police department the cops over
there really cool i talked to them
periodically i think they're great and
got nothing to worry about and then the
cast happened and i'm like
i'm gonna go buy some guns and you know
try to protect myself and take care of
myself
and now like it's kind of been like
crowder asked me
steven crowder he said would you now
something something like this would you
now recognize that
any law that would curtail your right to
own those guns is a bad law and i'm like
yeah actually yes yeah when when i
didn't think i needed it when i had the
luxury and privilege now
keeping in mind one of the reasons i
liked bernie in 2016
is that he said the divide between gun
owners
and those calling for gun control is
urban versus rural i thought that was
really interesting
he used to be he used to be on the level
but i guess he sold out and i think that
he was right about that because people
who live
way outside of cities they have
legitimate reasons for wanting a gun
like i was reading about texas where
these gigantic pigs would just run
through people's yards when their kids
were playing
yeah you want to ask why you need an
automatic weapon well if you have 30
peckeries running through your yard
i'm just saying i don't know about
automatic you know a big weapon bigger
than anyone in a city would
dream of needing yeah you want to make
sure that the wild animal because some
people like
chicago has coyotes yeah they'll eat
your dog
yeah they'll eat your cats coyotes are
awful yup yup
yeah so i remember this there was that
viral story about 30 was it 30 to 50
feral hogs
yes and then all these left is started
making fun of them
and it was really funny you see this
happen quite a bit with
urban liberals who think they're so much
smarter than everyone else
they think if you live on a farm and you
have a feral pig problem
you're a dumb hick so they made fun of
the guy
turns out 30 to 50 or whatever the meme
was
is quite a bit but there is an issue
where there are wild animals and you'll
need to defend your
your family your property your chickens
dude i had chickens in miami and i'm
really angry because they kept getting
killed
and i feel really bad about it because
it was my responsibility and i thought i
did everything right
we actually had a caged area but the the
i don't know what it i think of some
dogs
found their way in yeah so we ended up
we didn't know what it was
it turns out it was the neighbors the
the next house over they had a dog
and it was it had a gang had other dogs
so
we set up a trap by the chickens and
sure enough like
like an hour after i put it up in the
middle of the day we here
at the clank and i and and my uh my
brother's like dude
there's a dog in the trap and i was like
what i walked over the dog was snarling
and i was i talked him down
and then i let him out and i was like i
wasn't trying to catch it i thought it
was gonna be like some
some badger or some kind of crazy
critter or something
so then when the dog ran out i followed
it went to the neighbors
and i was like y'all owe me some
chickens yeah seriously
so i had no i i didn't know what the
appropriate way to deal with the dog was
i'm not going to shoot a dog
you know right the dog's a little bit
different we had a bunch of skunks that
we used to come through and eat our
chickens so we would trap
gunks would eat your chickens yeah
anything will eat a chicken that can get
to them like it's a serious delicacy
like it's not something that
they're just going to let go i love
those chickens those are my friends i'm
mad
i i love them because they were my first
job i raised them and i sold their eggs
i was 10 years old and i had a little
bucket full of money that i had earned
from them they were very important
but you you could get foxes whatever
yeah and so there's a divide there and
i've always been
you know kind of aware of that
especially when i lived on that farm in
miami and i would try and talk to my
liberal friends about
i i had a friend say there's literally
no reason anyone should ever need a gun
and i was just like that's just not true
that is something and i would tell the
stories
you know about protecting yourself yeah
well we haven't even touched on the
topic
of how long it takes the cops to get to
your house because where i lived there
wasn't
a police department there was a fire
department and we were about 15 minutes
from the city
uh about eight miles or something i
don't remember what exactly it was there
weren't any cops so if someone breaks
into your house in the middle of the
night
you got to deal with things your own way
and you might not have much of a choice
if it's somebody really
crazy you know you know it's funny too
about like lori lightfoot
saying you know we need federal gun laws
what if they break in with a knife or a
sword or a machete
yeah so so your gun is banned you're
gonna sword fight the guy well this is
what happened in london
they have very strict gun laws and they
don't have a lot of gun crime but they
do have a lot of knife crime and people
get stabbed in the streets
all the time so you think self-defense
is important anywhere and lori lightfoot
knows it this is why she has protection
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live
monday through friday at 8pm if you want
to catch the full show
tune in to this channel subscribe hit
the like button or
check us out on itunes and spotify and
we will soon have this podcast up for
free
on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next episode